for as long as Counter-Strike has
existed the AK-47 has been King it's on
short Shadow 103 to try and keep it
alive otherwise we'll go to a Fifth map
in the grad files shocks tabs out one
that's a deadly kill goes for the second
and he's moving closer looking for the
quad clutch here FNX the last man alive
he's gonna tap the bomb once
but as we all know only the T side has
access to this Holy Grail of weapons in
CS go the CTS can choose between two
slightly weaker premium rifle options
the m4a4 and the m4a1s and for as long
as they've both been in the game players
have debated as to which of the two is
superior uh m4a4 uh quite simply because
it's uh better uh actually I think it's
really uh more enjoyable to play with
the M4 air1s because of its silencer and
except for early on the m4a4 has been
widely regarded as the better option for
the majority of global offensive's
lifespan that is until operation Riptide
changed everything why play is still
completely unscathed for Eternal Fire
Flash Forward the tower is going to see
so many he transfers back makes it
foreign
buff buried in the largest CS go update
we've ever had ended up changing the
game in ways that no one could have ever
imagined the m4a1s became a death ray
that was all but impossible to ignore so
what exactly is it that makes the a1s so
busted these days did valve's attempt to
Nerf it actually do anything and is it
being broken sort of a good thing
so despite being the only Primo rifle
for the CTS in the franchise's earlier
iterations the silenced M4 wasn't
actually in CS go at release but to be
fair at one point the Galil had a red
dot sight and the guns sounded like this
however on August 14th of 2013 valve
released the infamous arms deal update
that blessed the game with skins staties
and of course the return of the a1s a
lot of you may not know this but in the
early days the a1s actually boasted
marginally better stats than its sibling
it was 200 bucks cheaper had slightly
more damage and accuracy at long ranges
and did more penetration damage on top
of that it wasn't as noisy as the A4 and
it had no tracers meaning that this gun
was great for holding rad angles or
spamming smokes that a team could
potentially pick up two major titles
are you joking he's gonna pick up a
triple kill goes with the USB not gonna
get the quad but they do it fanatic but
with all that being said the A4 did
boast one advantage over the a1s more
bullets specifically 10 more bullets per
magazine and 90 in reserve compared to
the measly Ford 30 in the a1s this meant
that you could use the A4 to rack up
huge multi-kills without needing to
reload so not giving them any opening
rpk pushing into the back and he goes
he goes shots he picks up one and goes
back for more he has no grenades
luminosity in overtime here looking for
the short shots gonna pick up one more
triple Playboy
he gets every single one and keeps the
dream alive still despite the bullet
Advantage a few months after the a1s's
release CS Go's first major rolled
around and both m4s saw some pretty even
usage but as the competitive scene
progressed Pro's preferences began to
shift towards the a1s it seemed like
many players were ditching the extra
ammo for a little bit more power and
accuracy don't take that as biased in
any way shape or form though because LGB
definitely they have uh they've
impressed a lot of people with
particularly their performance of a
fanatic yeah definitely their winner of
automatic was not really expected but
Pasha here getting three huge headshots
so throughout most of 2015 the a1s
reigned Supreme on CT side but Val was
not about to just sit idly by and let
that happen and by the 2016 cologne
major the m4a4 was back on top the a1s
practically vanished from the
competitive scene but the question was
why what exactly had happened to the a1s
why weren't the pros using it well by
the end of 2017 the differences between
the guns in the M4 family were more
apparent than ever before both the a1s
and A4 cost the same and technically did
the same amount of damage but the A4
still had more bullets and now crucially
a higher rate of fire the a1s did have a
few advantages like a much more
controllable spray pattern and less
damage fall off and after valve's second
shot update you could more easily Tap
Away with the a1s from long range but as
useful as that may seem it simply didn't
fit into the meta as CS go grew and
developed players got more aggressive on
T side and began using utility more
dynamically CDs needed to have the
bullets and speed at their disposal the
A4 outclassed its silenced counterparts
in every way that mattered it even got
the same second shot update making
equipping the a1s seem almost pointless
by comparison it's different like there
you know
it's situational because you have
players that are solely playing on AIM
and they're like tapping like if you
take screen in the old days or or maybe
Nico or players like this
I think they could be pretty good with
the A1 but only in like certain
situations yeah because when you need to
spray down a few people who are rushing
that that's very hard with the A1 valve
did attempt to make small Buffs to the
a1s to increase its usage they opt the
rifles Reserve ammo brought the mag size
up to 25 and eventually reduced its
price to 2 900 still by 2020 the a1s
barely saw any use and with the wildly
overpowered Krieg being the focus of
everyone's complaints there was little
time left to mull over how to make the
silencer actually viable but then came
2021 and with it operation Riptide
buried within a sea of stickers short
matches and shiny new Doppler Glocks was
one simple sentence that flipped the
status quo on its head the M4 a1s now
does more damage to the body but but
before we start spitting science about
what a laser beam this turned the a1s
into I must chill ever so quickly about
how zowie's brand new XL
2566k monitor can better help you
eviscerate fools with it you see one of
the benefits of zowie's patented and
oft-praised diac plus technology is that
it helps with spray control in CS go now
that you really need it when using the
a1s but still
can't hurt by finessing how and when
backlighting is turned off and on at
fixed points on the panel diac plus
removes unwanted after images and hugely
reduces motion blur seriously I know I'm
chilling but if you've never tried out a
zowie display you should the difference
is very noticeable
oh no oh
you're gonna swing that I can attest to
this since zowie was kind enough to send
me a 360 Hertz Monitor and I have been
absolutely slamming on it it causes
every movement to feel super telegraphed
and especially as a 16x9 boy allows me
to pick out elusive targets
fire nice
could be under Palace nice
[Music]
anyway back to the a1s so what exactly
did this damage change entail well
exactly what you'd expect the silencer
still took two shots to the head but
could kill anyone anywhere on the map
with only four shots to the body and
because the a1s was laughably easy to
control what was previously a woefully
underpowered noob Cannon became a laser
beam of death aggressive and it's
actually no gold too much shots out of
shocks eight a third for good
measurement oh my God
just on for the double astralis looking
silly Mia just popping another head
anyone else the effects just gonna fall
as well so you could deny this with a
one-way taking the fight what is going
on a flash an incentury from his
teammate to cover him and again Nico's
plans are foiled look at him go Pampas
he's so clinical the doctor nip need
the remedy provided for making an a
campus shuts it down in the first round
of overtime and now the guy who actually
knows what he's talking about
Counter-Strike might actually be the
most complex FPS
ever created simple is the Undisputed
goat of Cs go and if you want to play a
competitive tactical shooter
it was a dream
oh I'm like a nightmare
[Music]
no in case you haven't noticed I don't
exactly know a whole lot about
counter-strike's Arsenal so instead
let's talk about graphs just over a
month after the Patch around the time of
the Stockholm major the m4a4 literally
disappeared from use but eliminating one
CT weapon especially with csgo's massive
skin Market while incredibly
counter-intuitive isn't even the biggest
issue CS go as even the uninitiated like
Mino is an asymmetrical game at its core
and defending a bomb site is inherently
easier than attacking one so when you
buff one of the defending team's rifles
you don't just affect the balance of the
rifles on that side of the field you're
changing the balance of the entire game
if we look at the stats of each map in
the competitive pool before the patch we
can see that most skew slightly in favor
of the CTS except for maps like dust 2
and vertigo that leaned t-sided but in
2021 every single map became heavily
ct-sided and the patch only came out at
the end of that year just look how crazy
things got in 2022 to say that this
change affected the competitive scene
would be a bit of an understatement
t-sides were getting absolutely rinsed
especially after the release of ancient
which is statistically the single most
ct-sided stomping ground in Pro play
no longer does have to show the weight
all alone bro land oh he's gonna just
mowed them down
please
unreasonable man this is so unreasonable
so unreasonable they had guns bids they
had guns and Roland
they just wall backed them all the way
through Oblivion and that was the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about for a short time
this was really fun people missed the
silencer and it was a fun Nostalgia trip
to see it on top again but once the
honeymoon period was over everyone was
forced to admit that the overtuned a1s
was a problem from that one guy who
comments on all of our videos to the
majority of Pros it was Dirt Cheap did a
crazy amount of damage hid tracers had
zero recoil and made it so that if the
tease didn't hit their opening headshot
in long-range engagements they were
toast as painful as it was to spend all
those years lighting people 98-4
this was a step too far how has the a1s
become too powerful because I'm just
gonna say I think it's too powerful I
think I think in some respect right now
it's too strong things carried on this
way for over half a year finally valve
decided to make a tweak hoping it would
bring the silencer back in line with the
A4 on June 15th of 2022 the a1s's
magazine size was reduced back down to a
far less generous 20 bullets did it make
a difference
I mean sort of not really the Hope Was
That by making the a1s's mag size 66 of
the a4s it would drastically reduce the
silencer's potential for multi-kills the
issue is that even with 20 bullets you
are pretty much always good for three
the m4a4 still has its uses and there
are still amazing otherworldly riflers
like bit who can conduct a symphony
orchestra with it but for all of us
Mortals The a1s is just far too good to
pass up he's gonna go for it again he's
still out there Freeman he's got a smoke
in hand and he's dead and Maggie's while
they are setting up that long push just
absolutely picking it apart that is
frustrating fan King wow if he would
have pulled the trigger I can't believe
it magisk is he's wrecking them in this
round he's got 24 kills and he's gonna
get that last one too quad kill if we
look at recent results from cologne
blast and EPL the m4a4 is still
basically non-existent and if we look at
the map balance over the last six months
it still favors the CTS so valve's Nerf
didn't really change all that much the
question
is are we okay with that in principle
sure we as a community want the silencer
to be viable we just don't want it to be
the only sensible Choice the last year
or so has treated us to some fantastic
CS go and as op as it feels to beam
someone with the a1s in the right hands
the AK-47 is still the goat two headshot
D2 counting on Nico and Nexa anything
left the stylish one out of Perfecto
Nico
he's gonna be pushed to OT or can he
claw something oh
two to go but just because the Cs is
great doesn't mean it couldn't be better
because let's be honest getting shut
down trying to take a sight round after
round by five twenty nine hundred dollar
CT deletion tools spamming you through
smoke is a frustrating experience to
both play and watch
decides to get involved he's done
waiting around okay and in one mag he's
laid waste to G2 the t's are supposed to
have cheaper more potent Weaponry than
the CTS it's what offsets the fact that
the onus is on them to take map control
and while the AK is still technically
Superior in those respects it doesn't
always feel that way though that is not
to say that it's crazy to enjoy the
current state of the game the m4a1s is
broken it has nuked csgo's map balance
and rendered the A4 almost useless valve
could leave things as they are but the
whole point of buffing the a1s was to
get a more balanced representation of
both CT rifles and the way things stand
right now that simply isn't the case but
the honest solution to what valve should
do Warren's a discussion should the
m4a1s go back to the way it was before
or is there a different change you think
could be made to balance the more could
they invert the prices so the A4 is
cheaper or do valve need to go a step
further and increase the a1s's recoil or
Hell shave even more bullets off the
silencer's mag so the CTS really feel it
you tell us
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock
foreign